i was liking it to truman show have you
seen that movie
between the truman show and being in a
zoo prince harry compares life as a
royal
to a mix of being in a zoo and the
truman show
somebody help me i'm being spontaneous
the duke of sussex opens up about royal
life in the latest episode of dax
shepherd's armchair expert podcast
and says it's a lot like jim carrey's
1998 film
about a man who discovers that his whole
life is a reality show
let's get off this math shop we can't
see his face go to the cabin
cabin can
[Music]
there perfect that's our hero shot
the mix between the truman show and
being in a zoo to illustrate his point
harry details one of his first public
outings with his now wife meghan markle
saying they went to the supermarket in
london and had to pretend they didn't
know each other
so we text each other from the other
side of cloak and
there are people looking at me giving me
all these weird looks and coming up and
saying hi whatever
and i was like texting it's like is this
the right one she goes no you want
parchment paper i'm like okay
the 36 year old revealed that he first
thought about leaving his royal duties
behind
in his early 20s after repeatedly being
told to quote
grin and bear his problems and get on
with it
i don't want this job i don't want to be
here i don't want to be doing this
look what it did to my mum how am i ever
gonna you know settle down
have a wife and a family when i know
that it's gonna happen again
because i know i've seen behind the
curtain i've seen the business model i
know how this operation
runs and how it works yeah i don't want
to be part of this
of course harry's mom princess diana
died in 1997 in a car crash after being
chased down by paparazzi
i think the biggest issue for me was
that being born into it you inherit the
risk you inherit
every element of it without choice and
because of the way that the uk media
are they feel an ownership over you you
don't have a choice but then
of course then people quite rightly will
turn around and go so what if you didn't
have a choice it was privileged
it was only after his now wife meghan
markle encouraged him to go to therapy
that he addressed his long-held feelings
she saw it straight away she could tell
that i was hurting
and that some of the stuff that was out
of my control
was making me really angry and it would
make my blood boil
i think for harry who's spoken quite um
emotionally
about the the stress and the pressure of
having the paparazzi says every time he
hears the click of a shutter the pop of
a flashbulb it reminds him of his mother
and what she went through
harry said that feeling helpless is his
quote achilles heel
largely due to three moments in his life
one when i was a kid in the back of the
car my mom being chased by paparazzi
two was in afghanistan in an apache
helicopter
and then the third one was with my wife
and those are the moments in my life
where
yeah feeling helpless hurts it really
hurts
yeah and that's when you think yourself
like i got the privilege i've got the
platform i've got the influence and even
i can't fix this yeah i can't change
this
and when you start getting in your head
about it that's when it starts sort of
taking a toll
but harry says that therapy helped to
change all that
i was like okay you're in this position
of privilege
stop complaining or stop thinking as
though you want something different
make this different because you can't
get out
yeah so how are you going to do this
differently how are you going to make
your mum proud
how are you going to use this platform
to really affect change
and be able to give people that
confidence to be able to change their
own lives
despite harry's best efforts he and
megan announced their plan to step down
as senior members of the royal family in
january 2020
their exit was confirmed in february
after a year-long trial period
the general consensus is that this
divorce
has worked megan and harry left the
royal family to become independent to
become
financially independent and they have
absolutely achieved that this year they
can now look back
a year on and and probably celebrate
their decision of course the couple made
the move to california and started their
own foundation
archwell the sussexes i think feel very
far away from us over here in the uk
they're
they're in l.a they're putting they're
putting their
time and energy into really important
causes
living here now i can actually like lift
my head
and actually i feel different my
shoulders have dropped so is hers
you can walk around feeling a little bit
more freer
you